no I just think they're so funny they're
so funny and the writers on the show are
so [ __ ] funny
it's called sorry sorry yeah right there
are you sure I have a question for your
celebrity now my question is when you
see another Asian like you've never
heard of before let's say for instance
like someone your age and who is also
doing sketch who's like me that babbling
and stand up or you see like a younger
like female like stand-up comedian Duke
do you get your spikes go up or are you
more like hey like you do want to get to
know them and nurture them are you more
like who that what is this [ __ ] about
yeah like you feel like a threat or do
you feel like an Asian girl that's cute
yeah right um I think I'm curious what's
wrong is it the cats I have a cough
she's highly allergic to cats by the way
yeah okay no no I had a Allegra okay
good like there's a San Francisco girl
girl named moon you know her no yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but she
seems you know funny right yeah yeah
yeah I don't I've never seen her perform
either but you guys tell though right
because of the way she's dressed and
that's another thing I was saying is is
that you can already tell that when she
talks and the way she looks and who
she's dating and how she behaves that
she's not a [ __ ] fob Oh what is the
real definition of a father isn't fresh
off the boat right so there's energy
there's
different kinds alright there's the
literal kind yeah up somebody that just
came here yeah I mean they're from like
you know Taiwan right and they they have
a thick accent and they'd and they
shower once a week yeah yeah that's or
whatever but you don't know you don't
know what they don't know okay computer
they've never seen a Wes Anderson movie
shut the [ __ ] up man I'm talking I'm
talking okay and they don't know who I
am right no but then those that kind and
then there are the ones that were born
here right I'm gonna name a name but I
grew up with a guy named John right the
nicest kid John go bungu John Lee oh
yeah it's my brother it is really yeah
and he always got straight A's my
parents would always go why don't you
hang out with him he's smart
you do you get better at it you know you
do Parag that's why I don't hang out
with him because he's just he doesn't go
out all he does is read he's gonna
become a doctor and whatever don't they
call those like so fobs are generally
like the 1.5 hours right that generation
where they probably came to the US right
around like 13 14 so they still retain
all of their like they say for instance
like for me like they're you know like
yeah my accent or like my mannerisms
didn't shave my legs I was very like
studious and then then you acclimated
yep it took me a while my accent was
very very thick most of my teen years
and I had like a weird look I dressed
not cool but then you started blowing
guys I started blowing guys really care
about my father [ __ ] let me just suck
some big oh my god I was like really cuz
my parents never like talked about sex
or anything of that sort you know side
to figure a lot of stuff out of my own
and initially when I first came from
America I would write boys letters like
hey I like you cuz that's what we did in
the Philippines right that [ __ ] don't
fly here really you'll write letters cuz
you're [ __ ] weak [ __ ] if you do that
and so I got rejected and after
rejection me just suck your dick and it
works the American Way it's American Way
you just yeah just blow your way to you
know out of your table eNOS yeah yeah
Wow yeah blow your way out of five yeah
now all of a sudden I wasn't a father
anymore it was just a chicken head you
know that's what they should have that
in like what's the first thing for when
you it wouldn't be blowing with me the
first thing but that would be like in
the back pages yes like like an Asterix
and a little like red in red yeah tiny
choice out yes advance
writing a letter you put so much heart
into writing a letter right yeah I
remember this yo Rican guy named Gary he
was like what the [ __ ] is this yeah that
was just not the way to go
I think letters are a woman thing no I
think it's a fob thing maybe because
none of the kids there was she writes
letters I write letters and I was born
here I'm so embarrassed yeah but like so
you know moon who is you know you can
just tell and how do you feel if you see
like when you were younger I know now
you're a little bit better about seeing
like another Asian okay I'm gonna just
say this right now okay I'm going to say
this right now when I did Jay Leno
right the next day a guy calls me right
an Asian guy from New York and he was
represented by Barry Katz
you know Barry Katz yeah hey dude I just
saw you tonight sure dude I'm Korean too
and um you [ __ ] killed it I go what
because yeah my name is Steve burn he's
happy wow I didn't even know him right
he goes I begged my manager he was Rutte
by Barry Katz to get your number and you
know I just want to be your friend
way yeah and so and I was like that when
ken Jeong when I first saw ken Jeong I
go
ken Jeong a myspace message you did yeah
really funny Thanks yeah yeah so like
you you you know you see guys you go all
but then when it's but when you see
somebody that isn't doing the you
the way you like there was a guy named
Peter Chen and you you met Peter Chan
right I feel so bad because Peter tan
was here during the eighties during the
boom open mic
he has thick accent you know I mean look
he has a documentary on YouTube about
him hated himself oh okay right
and he I mean nice guy just a terrible
comedian thick accent and he had he made
up like you know when hecklers he made
up lines that didn't make any sense
right so arm hey you say oh I saw anyway
you saw oh yeah I'm gonna put you on a
rocket ship you wanna go to go to the
moon but that was that was his lamb yeah
like he would write swims there will be
another one what would be another one
hey your mom is a gross I think the
[ __ ] in the ground you go in I'd give
you you can dig your way out like that
like stuff that you would go oh my god
that's so not funny
yeah you know and then one day I was at
the open mic and he would used to put
just put me up on the open mic and he
had signed up and he had been there for
25 years or whatever so I remember him
approaching me god it's got a yeah oh
yeah 25 yeah yeah no you're not fired
alright so it's like that with that kind
of [ __ ]
I'm verbal about it yeah when I see
people that I think have like you I what
I genuinely think that you have genuine
I can't look at you when I give you a
compliment I can I'm gonna go to your
right a little bit faster
no I'm gonna look at you yeah to the
right a little bit but Gilbert I
genuinely think that you have genuine
talent and that you're you literally can
make it I feel that about Esther Gilbert
at the CBS diversity showcase I don't
want this to be a [ __ ] we look great
like this is sounding sad that's [ __ ]
hard cast but I'm just saying that's my
point okay
I barely give compliments let me just
give one alright that's true
so if you saw an Asian girl asked her if
you saw an Asian girl that was good that
you would probably support her then
you know what I am always curious
because there's so few of us yeah you
know I think it's good to embrace other
people the way you embrace me yeah
as mark would embraced you or no you
know what I stalked her one time well
yeah but this you know who you are
well she follows me on Twitter I
remember when she when her sitcom
all-american girl got canceled yeah and
you PO you a kid
yeah I was a kid and I was watching this
on TV and I remember thinking like this
is a big deal the first Asian American
to ever get a sitcom deal was huge yeah
and I remember they were interviewing
her they're like so Margaret what are
you gonna do now and she's like well I'm
just gonna keep kicking ass till the
next Asian American girl gets up here
and I just like took that and like I
know yeah you know I'm gonna make me cry
now I was like I was like oh I'm gonna
she's speaking to me I just yeah I just
like just took it yeah
[Music]